I've seen loads of YouTube videos
telling me that the Stargate Revival
won't be a Revival it's gonna be a hard
reboot a remake
what are we to believe welcome to
Sidetrack your Sci-Fi TV movie channel
[Music]
if you are regular Sidetrack you'll know
that I talk about Stargate quite a lot
and I've actually been telling you for a
year that this is not going to be a
remake or a hard reboot that even though
the hard reboot conversations have been
had that there are people at MGM that
believe a hard reboot is the way to go
that actually even MGM have spoken to
Roland Emerick and Dave Devlin about
maybe redoing their original plan for a
trilogy but the even Roland emmerich
told us himself that Amazon and MGM know
that the TV audience are what matters
and therefore we can infer from that
that there will be no remake
so why are there so many people on
YouTube saying that there will be so
many YouTube channels telling everyone
that there's gonna be a remake well it's
because they've read the deadline report
a couple of weeks ago now deadline
reported that there's going to be a
Stargate movie that there's going to be
a Robocop moving a couple other things
as well coming out of MGM over the next
year to 18 months
that they're working on this project
right now and that even though this
announcement will not have been a
surprise to anybody that watches
Sidetrack that did surprise a lot of
other people so they did their little
videos trying to get clicks and a lot of
them believe from that report that it
was going to be a remake of the original
Stargate but why would they infer that
well the way deadline reported it they
didn't really say either way they just
sort of said we believe it's probably
going to be a movie
so people have assumed because well they
don't watch this channel maybe and
they've assumed that would be a remake
why because well that's what Hollywood
always does after this bigger gap
between the old series ending and you
know the new franchise started hopefully
next year the normal way of doing that
is a remake is a complete hard reboot
but I don't think that's really where
we're at at the moment the success of
things like the new Quantum Leap series
did pretty well Picard season three and
lots of other sort of revivals have
really paved the way that actually the
executives can be a little bit Brave
when it comes to Stargate they can do a
Star Trek the Next Generation style
hybrid reboot and I've been told for a
very long time that's what Amazon are
pushing for the Amazon know they cannot
afford to have a bunch of negativity
about the Stargate project being thrown
around YouTube before the show even gets
filmed I've mentioned it to you guys a
couple of times that there's this ring
of power problem that YouTube went crazy
over rings of power and it brought so
much negativity into the show that it
really affected View and figures
now they don't want the same again
because they know how well-loved a
franchise like Stargate is they also
look at Star Trek and how much
negativity has been aimed at Alex
kurtzman they'd quite like to avoid some
of that as well so very early on my
sources were telling me that Amazon have
said very clearly this must be a
continuation but I mentioned hybrid
reboot what do I mean by that well
well it has been nearly 20 years since
Stargate left our screens
it has been a big gap and there will be
new creators coming in to make the
series and hopefully the movie those
creators are gonna want to bring in some
of their own ideas they're gonna want
some fresh blood they may want to take
the series in a slightly different
direction now that is going to scare
some of you but I really don't want you
to be too afraid
because as long as they get the right
team in and hopefully that will be Mark
Fergus of the penguin the Parker team
the guys that brought us the expanse a
person that we happen to know from a
couple of leaked meetings that we've
discussed in the past that he is a huge
Stargate fan
then I think this can go the right way
and I think that them bringing their own
ideas are not necessarily sticking very
strictly to Canon could be a good thing
for the show overall I have talked to
you in the past about how there are a
few problems we're bringing this show
back that really by the end of sg1 the
Towery was so powerful that you have to
wonder what that show is going to look
like now another 20 years has gone by we
do still want to show that feels like
Stargate not a futuristic completely
unrealistic Sci-Fi show that perhaps we
might be in danger of getting something
more like Star Trek so allowing the new
creators a little bit of freedom
might be a very good way of avoiding
some of those landmines now is there
still any possibility of a hard reboot
I'm afraid until the final decision has
been made and is still and until we
actually start seeing some names like
Amanda Tapping being attached to this
then I will always be slightly afraid of
the hard reboot now does that mean that
show will be a disaster does it mean I
won't watch it
well it would still be a show at very
least inspired by my favorite show so I
will still give it a chance but he'll be
with a heavy heart but honestly if I was
a betting man and honestly based on
everything I've been told by
whistleblowers and insiders for the last
12 months
that is not the plan they want to do a
Revival they want to get some of that
Nostalgia because I mean Picard season 3
showed really how A series that if I'm
honest isn't very good
still was incredibly popular and I still
jumped around when the Enterprise D came
out they're hungry even though I
completely expected it
just based on the Nostalgia the audience
and the stargaters will actually forgive
an awful lot if they give us enough
Nostalgia to enjoy and if nothing else
I think that's one reason why they'll do
it
so continuation
a Revival that's what we're currently
looking at now unless something
massively changes or something goes
horribly wrong that's what we can look
forward to
so if you come across a post or a
YouTube video saying this is going to be
a hard reboot Don't Panic just remember
what I've been telling you for over a
year and just trust
and Hope
that they do it justice but guys get
into the comments and tell me what you
think have you seen any of the videos
I'm talking about or memes or comments
do you actually believe for a second
Amazon is stupid enough to do a hard
reboot when so many of the actors are
still available and when the show has
actually not been off S screens that
long
I hope they're not
but get into the comments and tell me
what you think if you are new to the
Channel please like subscribe hit that
Bell notification it really helps us out
and you can also go over to patreon.com
forward slash Sidetrack whereas for a
small contribution each month that
really supports a channel you get to see
most of our videos first and you can
even do a seven day free trial so it's
free for a bit at least
as always guys please stay safe and I'll
see you next time
foreign